تاسست منظمه ايجاد عام
1996 على انقاذ منظمه التنميه ومحاربه
التصحر تضم المنظمه ثمانيه دول في منطقه
القرن الافريقي التي تواجه تحديات التنميه
والنزاعات الحدوديه والارهاب تبلغ مساحه
دول الايجاد مجتمعه خمسه ملايين ومئتين
الف كيلو متر مربع ويبلغ عدد سكانها 230
مليون نسمه كان الهدف الذي اعلنته المنظمه
عند تاسيسها هو تحقيق التنميه ومحاربه
الجفاف والتصحر الذي انهك اغلب دول
المنطقه لكن تحديات النزاعات الحدوديه
والارهاب ستفرض على المنظمه التي وجدت
نفسها في خضم نزاعات بين اثيوبيا والصومال
وجيبوتي والسودان وجنوب السودان وجيبوتي
واريتريا وكذا الارهاب في الصومال واوغندا
اما بالنسبه الى السودان فان منظمه ايجاد
سعد سنه 2003 الى ايجاد تسويه في اقليم
دارفور الذي شهد مواجهات داميه كما ان
الاهليه بين الجنوب والشمال التي استمرت
اكثر من عقدين من الزمن فرضت تحديات كبيره
على ايجاد واستمرت هذه التحديات بعد
استقلال دوله جنوب السودان وما شهدته
الدوله الفتيه من اضطرابات لم تنتهي بعد
ثوره 2019 والانقلاب العسكري الذي رافقها
ساهمت منظمه ايجاد في جهود ايجاد حل عبر
اقتسام السلطه بين العسكريين والمدنيين في
انتظار حل نهائي ياتي بسلطه مدنيه والان
وبعد اندلاع المواجهات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع تحاول ايجاد مره اخرى البحث
عن صيغه حل تجنب السودان انفجار شاملا
تعرف انه خطر ستنتقل اثاره الى كل دول
المنظمه